whoa
what was that brentwood uh um it's radio
time with hans and ryan
[Music]
i'm a ding-dong
okay all right cut that
okay three two one
hello hello hey everyone it's good to be
here my name is riley and
this is hans and we're here to do
another comedy podcast
comedy podcast uh you know are though
all the rage today i think my mom has
one you know it's just like
it's it's just so fun it's so lucrative
and
i hope you guys will have a really good
time
yeah something else you know wash the
dishes
walk your dog listen to this podcast
listen to another podcast
this is a uh this is yeah this is meant
to be listened to
while listening to another one this is
like an additional like supplemental
podcast
yeah you can listen to music while you
listen to this podcast
so um what's been going on with you
lately we got to kill tony yesterday
no big deal yeah uh explain to the folks
at home what what that is
a kill tony is a stand-up comedy show
where
famous comedians let not famous
comedians do one minute
and then they make fun of them and
criticize the shape of their eyes on
live
internet youtube yeah all right well uh
so this guy tony h cliff has a
show where he brings open micros on and
people do a minute and han's [ __ ]
killed
thanks man the interview the minute of
stand up was just
really good and all around wow very good
i'm glad you think so because you're a
comedy connoisseur i'm a comedy observer
i observe it from afar not in a creepy
way
you're a stalker of comedy i bring
binoculars to comedy shows
so i can zoom up on the on the lips like
telling the joke
you can tell how nervous someone is by
the moisture in their mouth
really yeah what about the moisture of
their
relax that
can tell you how aroused they are at
comedy
um yeah so
yeah do you ever wish sex was drier
i find it to be too too moisturous
it's swampy it's like a
it's like a a cave made out of like gel
it's like a cave with like the outer
linings or like gel
and you have to like you know go through
the cave
and step on the jowl and stuff it's like
just like sometimes you want to just
get a rocky cave or just like a
cobwebs and bats something dry
i don't always want you're not going to
feel
but yeah but unfortunately around the
around you
the ladies just start gushing
gushers they can't help themselves
um yeah so
that's good man so um would like uh
what do you enjoy about going on kill
tony i enjoy staring at ron white
as he's staring at me yeah it is run
right and
wondering if i have the right facial
expressions
to convey honor and respect and also
humility and scaredness
yeah to ron white yeah
do you look up to him a lot yeah he was
like
one of the first comedians i really got
into really
yeah wow i've never uh
actually like i don't think i've seen
his stand-up
or like i've seen it a few times but
like i've never like
closely followed a stand-up but like
everyone i talked to is just like yeah
he's a legend
yeah he's so slow and steady it's like
he does a lot with a little he just says
like two words
yeah he was big with the blue collar
comedy tour
which is where he's right with um like
what's that other guy
jeff foxworthy yeah the cable guy yeah
bill engel but he was like the funniest
out of them in my opinion
yeah he's i mean certainly aged well
he's the most respectable
so it's like oh my god this guy's trying
to make me laugh i'm so honored that a
wise old sage
is trying to tickle my funny bone was he
was trying to tickle you
yeah felt like he was trying to tickle
me
with humor with humor not physically um
yeah i mean yeah he's seems like a great
great guy yeah he's interesting yeah
i mean he was just like when i saw him
at vulcan he was just like telling a
story
and it was just like it might have even
be
been the first time you told that story
but like he's just he knows like where
to go with his words
like which is insane like he like just
like he's already got the story mapped
out in his head like line by line
and like most people are so bad at
telling stories like that it's like
it's like yeah so like i was over here
and then i went over to uh
green yeah and then oh by the time did i
tell you about the time i went to cuba
and then it's just like
a different story yeah it's like
like oh and by the way he was a waiter
and that's like the punch line
oh you're supposed to tell me that right
right right
but yeah i mean when you do comedy that
long and you just know
how to tell a story and it's easy that
would be the best
where it just comes out of you like that
i mean that's what i mean
yeah and any guys who are like who've
been doing stand-up that long like
ron wyatt dave chappelle uh you know
[ __ ]
anyone anyone louis joe rogan joe rogan
yeah anyone who's doing stan anyone
who's like
mastered stand-up is like is a matcher
you know you could do it
just off the whim whenever you need to
yeah
and it's like we're riding a bike at
some point like
even if eddie murphy came back right now
he'd probably still be good
yeah i mean the thing with that is like
um he's he's doing a special
eddie murphy oh i didn't know about that
he is
uh where is he practicing i don't know
see that's the thing like i don't know
if he's practic
i mean he's he's probably practicing i
don't know though but like
uh that's what like that's what like
the other comedian podcasts i listen to
the better podcast than this
are like uh saying that's like they're
like
uh yeah like i don't know how he's gonna
do because like
i don't want to like ruin i don't want
him to like ruin his
whatever he had before you know yeah
it's just like
i mean but and like and also when you're
on that level like
uh everyone respects you so like
you're gonna get a a reaction either way
you know yeah it's just like you don't
well it's like interesting to see how he
interacts with us
as a society because he's been hiding
from us
yeah dude he like he went into he used
to be like
i wasn't alive but like he used to be
like
[ __ ] lively and just like yeah like
[ __ ] justin bieber
and now he's just like a dad
and just like a like a like a nevada dad
i don't know where he lives he's an
actor now
yeah but like i mean his most recent
[ __ ] was that uh
king to come back to america too and
then
but he didn't do i mean he did a little
bit but not like
a ton yeah he isn't
really honest with people he hasn't
really showed himself and been
vulnerable
to society and i think that's what a lot
of stand-up come on comedy is it's like
how do you relate to society you don't
think he's been vulnerable
no i think he's been hiding behind his
acting like it's easier
to act yeah but i mean he does stand
up now he does
oh are you tired well he was vulnerable
i mean
yeah i think he's vulnerable when he's
in public but like
he's just not in public is that what
you're saying well maybe face to face
but like just to the general audience
like to
society as a whole to pop culture
he hasn't really done comedy and when he
did comedy when he was young he was like
you got like you [ __ ] [ __ ] and
stuff like that
like he would uh be super ostentatious
yeah he was like showing off like this
crazy you know
standoffish side of himself dude well i
mean the con the style of comedy has
like evolved like
like doing modern comedy now is just
like
it's basically like a theater play like
a high school theater play it's just
like
you got to be vulnerable and [ __ ] but
like i feel like stand-up comedy back
then was just like
ah midgets you know gay people
they were just happy to see someone on
stage they're like wow this is crazy
yeah he's saying and now it's like more
performancy if
i feel like yeah it's more
[Music]
one-man showy or like therapy
yeah like a a root uh
a road down uh
gender lane i don't know a trick i don't
know
gender lane i mean uh
i mean i think that he was caught with a
transgender
prostitute in his car eddie murphy yeah
when
in like the 90s or 80s oh right and then
that's when he stopped doing comedy
really yeah i didn't know that yeah
damn um so i think he was embarrassed by
that
probably because he's always saying how
much he hates gay people
yeah because he is a little
and it's just like okay you're the one
wearing a leather suit
[Laughter]
and he's very skinny and yeah
i wasn't alive back then so i don't know
but uh yeah i mean i think it's hard to
be vulnerable
especially when you come from that
culture of the 80s when you're not
supposed to be gay
yeah dude but uh i like louis has this
joke about like
um gay people like i think it's louis oh
it's just like
you know gay people it like it probably
sucks now to be gay because like it used
to be like so
cool like you would [ __ ] [ __ ] in an
alleyway or you know it used to be like
secretive
like behind the scenes and now it's just
like all in the open like getting
married and [ __ ] it's just like boring
it's like you made it boring it's like
you it's like
it's not as like sexy and risky you know
it's like being gay now is picking out
your white picket fence
yeah floral patterns yeah back then it
used to be like
going to a dirty club and finding an
[ __ ] to stick your dick in
yeah and like that's weird because like
uh i
like yeah that's it's like it's like if
if that's what it takes to be gay
you know the gay people are like i guess
i have to do that you know even though i
wouldn't normally go
to a sleazy club but now i like i have
to do this because i want to be gay i
care more about being gay than i do
about going to a sleazy cub
sometimes like it's it's like that with
like a lot of things like for comedy
it's just like i don't want to like be
going to bars and [ __ ] all the time but
like i have to because i want to be a
stand-up comedian
yeah it's like it's like forces you out
of your comfort zone
and the standard is basically like being
gay
you go to clubs you reveal your parts of
yourself you wish you had it revealed
blow men you blow
you blow you blow into a hard
phallic object
black black uh
you're out of breath you're sweating
yeah and you're like whispering you're
trying to violate
trying to persuade people
um yeah but uh
i think that we're getting better as
comedians but i also think that we'd be
better if
we had economic security
and also the advances that we had in
terms of gay and transgender stuff
what what are you talking about like
modern comedy
i think there's too much survival in
modern comedy people are
using it to survive dude what are you
talking about
that's what like comedy is more
lucrative than it's ever been
like in the [ __ ] 80s dude they were
they were making
[ __ ] like they didn't yeah i mean
granted it was before you get
to the lucrative level there's a lot of
desperation
yeah but it's always been that way um i
think back in the past it was maybe
a little easier to get a human you would
like go straight to shows
because there wasn't that many comedians
so like you didn't have to do the open
mics for like eight years
you know back in the day you would only
do it for like
one or two or because there's not as
many yeah
well i just feel like nowadays it's like
people are like this is my career
this is who i am i need to be successful
at this or i'll die
and it makes comedy a lot more boring
and a lot more
i don't know like do you think it makes
it more boring i think that's like what
like an
art like an artist pushes himself like
to
to write the hackiest jokes that'll work
in on the road
yeah how can i write that joke that'll
make me the most money
yeah um well if that's what you care
about
or yeah i mean if that's what you need
to do but like
you can still you know that's only good
for people like joe rogan
who's like oh survival i'll be the most
neutral podcast host ever and do it a
bunch
uh i guess he wasn't struggling to
survive no yeah he wasn't
but like when he got to the big time
it's just like his personality type is
the one that's rewarded
like people who work really hard but
might not be the most creative the fans
that he brings in like
um like at the vulcan shows like all
college kids
and like big heavy drinkers partiers
like the the fans of joe rogan are like
don't like yeah i mean a lot of dudes
yeah but like are like
not huge comedy fans like in general i
feel like
the ones who buy tickets to joe rogan
shows i mean you
maybe that's the case with like a lot of
comedians a lot of comedians have their
own audience
yeah i mean well joe rogan even more so
it makes sense
yeah the podcast and like ufc and [ __ ]
like joe rogan like applies to like
[ __ ] bros yeah you know and it's
and it's like and all like across a
bunch of different levels
so that that's what really works for joe
rogan it's just like
multi-platform yeah
and yeah like dude like he's like he's
like like
he's he's easily likable like he's he's
a like
he's just like a dude you know he's just
like a guy like he's like what you have
to become
what we idealize this is who we think is
the best
it's like this simple yeah do you know
how much elk meat sales have gone
up since joe rogan started eating elk i
don't know if you're allowed to sell elk
because yeah it's a wild game they don't
want to create a market because then
people will go out and
harvest the and kill all the elk to make
money
but i would buy elk if they sold it at
whole foods
yeah can i get the elk um and uh just
brown rice
the elk taco the bulgogi elk taco
korean elk food oh i saw a video of like
they were
he was using like bulgogi sauce what is
that is that like soy
teriyaki sauce yeah it's like teriyaki
sauce i don't know
i have i don't know you know bolognese
it's my probably my least favorite type
of pasta is bolognese
first of all the name not appetizing
whatsoever
second of all the shape of it it's too
big i
my fork goes through the pasta like the
the thing is like this big round
and uh that's just like dude
come just give me a [ __ ] regular
pasta like
okay like angel hair spaghetti
linguini ravioli
sometimes what about notes i like the
spiral one
uh rotini or rotini yeah
uh no key is good but it
it's yeah it's good if it's like so soft
yeah it's good
great texture um but it's also like
i would prefer to eat multiple pastas at
once not just like one gnocchi
you know you want like a pot that's why
i say ravioli sometimes because it's
just like i'm eating
i'm eating a like a half a rally half a
ravioli
yeah and also you can't trust the
stuffing sometimes the stuffing is gross
yeah but um
yeah so i think i'd just rather have
like long pieces of pasta
like angel hair angel hair yeah
that's what i like really because i like
i like twirling it up in this
in my fork and then like
and uh what if they had a pasta that was
just rolled up angel hair
except you didn't have to roll it up you
just had to stick your fork in the
middle of it yeah i wouldn't like that i
like
like swishing it around and stuff and i
i like i like when it like hangs off my
mouth a little bit like
like i like that i think it looks i mean
it doesn't look cool but like
i like uh maybe to the lady and the
[ __ ]
yeah it's just classic you know it's
classic pasta like
slurping a pasta so when you're eating
you're like tapping into italian
yeah tap into all the nostalgia
of pasta and pasta
is looks a lot better than it tastes
in my opinion like if you see like a big
pot of pasta you're like damn that looks
good that
that smells pretty good but like it's
just like wheat rolled up
wheat yeah it's a lot of work
you have to eat it you get full really
quick
and you just at some point you're just
like going through the motions
yeah yeah yeah right i mean
that's the case with like anything you
you're eating where you're full already
and you're just like
uh i might as well finish this yeah it's
like
i you should really save it for when
you're actually hungry i know
but then i'm like ah then i have to heat
it up you know
it's gonna get soggy like i might forget
it and it might rot
yeah and it's just like i might as well
eat it now while it's like fresh
and also
i can't control myself also like i
even when i my body is telling me i'm
full i'm like no
how come you have such a problem with
food but you're still so skinny
um i don't know maybe
you're just aware of it maybe you don't
like it a lot
huh huh
what i mean my body can only take so
much it's not like i can
eat like a lot
yeah i mean the kava bowl is pretty good
i mean the pop the cover bowl is pretty
big
yeah um but i don't know dude i mean i
just love to
stuff my i don't know i think i have
like a high metabolism
i'm just lucky that way
yeah um and also uh
you know i i uh
i every time i eat i i reach out into my
stomach and grab it
you believe it throw it away yeah i'm
sort of like a
an advanced version of bulimic where i
can just
it's like a claw machine you're like a
sword swallower
uh yeah yeah i like i stick a spoon
in there and i like i don't know imagine
if they could have something that could
just suck away all the food you're
eating before it reaches your stomach
and you could just eat and eat
just for fun yeah they had that in
hunger games
where it's just like uh like they're
like
oh like drink this so you'll throw up
and be skinny
well we have that nowadays what's it
throwing up
i don't know i bet there's something
that makes you throw up
[Music]
yeah that's a tough one for women
yeah because they want to be skinny
yeah and it's just like more accepting
for guys to be fat
yeah because we can be rich yeah
and be attractive why isn't that the
case for women because they have to push
out a baby
they're the baby machines it doesn't
matter how much money you have if you
produce a shitty baby our species is
gonna die
what how would it be a shitty baby what
do you mean because they're in like
fat yeah and unhealthy there's a bunch
of glucose
floating around so we have to enforce
cultural standards of beauty to ensure
the next crop of humans will be healthy
um i guess when you put it like that
we have the fat shame for the good of
our society like i'm talking to
uh who's that [ __ ] jordan peterson oh
that guy with the
the sign was just like prove me wrong oh
stephen crowder yeah um
something crazy that's offensive and
you know in the back of your mind it's
wrong i think i think what that show
proves is
if you're allowed you're right if you're
loud and interrupted
you are correct if you have a lot of
confidence
and you can just put it vocally yeah
uh let's not get into politics
yeah i mean no one wants to hear that
no one likes politics i like your
neutral joke about poland gender neutral
you're like oh you know what's talking
about switzerland well world war
ii you're neutral i like that
dude i was thinking about that like how
crazy is that that switzerland and all
this neutral com
uh i was about to say companies
countries
same thing countries were just like they
saw what was happening in world war ii
all the [ __ ] insane [ __ ] and i was
just like
yeah i don't know i don't care i don't
go
like that yeah i don't know you know
that's one way to live your life
like like like 30 feet that way there's
a [ __ ] camp like a holocaust camp and
you're just like
like driving bats to go to burger king
like jesus christ dude
oh yeah that would be really jesus dude
you have to be really
a scared person to be neutral or smart
like look what happened to
czechoslovakia
they all their buildings were they are
not checked i think i mean there's
differences between being smart and
playing it safe because you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
well if you're switzerland you're a tiny
country germany and france are
engaging in this giant war you can only
do so much
like it makes sense does anyone want
lemonade
we need a water boy like why would they
engage
um i mean not engaged but
just be like in support of either side
i don't know yeah that's a complicated
thing but like
definitely you're a [ __ ] either way
yeah people didn't like that
it's safe like you're just you're not
fight i mean
at least put up i kind of [ __ ] them
because
they are now marginalized they're like
oh you didn't help us with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you it's like oh you don't matter
switzerland
who who said that the world the culture
like switzerland isn't a big part of our
culture
they don't get a voice because they
didn't well they want to do their own
thing and make [ __ ] watches or
whatever they can be our bank but
nothing more
we don't accept anything from
switzerland because we're like oh you're
just
you don't care about us all you care
about is yourselves you're not willing
to put yourself on the line like america
did
which we barely did yeah we we got there
at the like the end of the party we were
like you guys still
going yeah let me get it i guess
we were like we're like while they were
fighting we're like eating a sandwich
we're ready in a minute we're like
watching with binoculars
i'll be there in a second you guys are
doing great i'm five minutes away
meanwhile i just got on the interstate
keep your left arm up yeah you're doing
good good form
love your strategy and then when we get
there we're like ah all right
oh
uh russia is the mvp of world war ii
russia you know we don't give enough
credit to russia for world war ii
yeah because communism um
was that dirt world war two was that
before the cold war
uh i mean russia was communist in 1919
i guess we didn't like them before that
but we were too great depression-y
we're two great depressed depressed yeah
to do anything
tonight i don't want to fight you
communism
i'm having depression the great
depression
i wonder what they named it that
probably when it was
past good depression
mediocre depression i thought this was a
good depression this is a great
this depression really kicked it up a
notch um
yeah sad
russia how are we gonna go they just
threw bodies
at the problem until something happened
russia
yeah it's crazy yeah well
i mean yeah russia has a pretty
fighter mentality yeah
they're like i got it have you seen dan
soder's bit about
they're the scariest white people yeah
yeah i was like i thought about that
before i went to new york i was like
that's not a bad idea
when like if you had a russian accent
that would be legit when someone comes
up to you tries to mug you
what are you doing or i can't do it you
think this bad neighborhood
yeah i mean yeah that would probably
work
the russian is the only
i can't think of any others they're the
only scary white people
like even even the school shooter in
america is just like okay you're
without a gun you're an absolute [ __ ]
but like always wearing like
khaki pants and wearing headbands and
always like
running into cold water dude they don't
come up they don't give a [ __ ] man
they're always head banging and cutting
themselves yeah
they're like i think they're made out of
like a harder material
yeah i mean their history is crazy
they were just ruled by idiots yeah
and they just had to they're still
really smart though yeah
like all that computer hackers coming
from there yeah
super smart because i think they well
they have to spend a lot of time inside
it's probably why they're like
completely dostoyevsky
um yeah
letting lenin grad is a city
montgomery they're so they have like an
inferiority complex because they're like
they want to be europe so bad but
they're too far east
and none of the europeans see them as
europeans
they're like you're not europe yeah
they're pretty much asian no they're
asian i thought
well who knows i mean they're more
asiatic
i think well aren't they part of the
continent in asia yeah
yeah so they're asian but it's like uh
like canada how everything's in the
south
and the north is just nothing like the
east of russia is
nothing like there's no big state every
every big city is in the west in russia
yeah
but like that's it's still russia what
do you mean it's still asia
so asia i mean half of it is in europe
according to the whatever oh the
camera went out
who gives a [ __ ] about russia this is
the [ __ ] russians podcast
russia if you're listening to this
let's fight no i
started a war against russia on this
podcast after you call them tough
you're like they're the scariest white
people
but [ __ ] them uh
i don't know yeah i guess
there's i've i've seen some russian
films that i enjoy
uh dash cam
dash cam videos i didn't see any russian
films but like i learned about them
in the uh in my class the cold war and
like
in the 50s like the the it was like the
opposite culture of like here like
the women were like super independent
like and they they've always
like they've they've been like that for
a while like in russia
and like yeah i think that's cool
yeah that's crazy how it changed
uh yeah just like they would i would
watch like all these like
communist like propaganda films in that
class and it was just like
it was like one of them was just like
ants giant ants
uh attacked the town and it's just like
you know get in your houses bunker down
uh and then there's one where it's just
like
people would turn into rope people would
turn into these like alien
robots like aliens would like take over
their bodies and make them into like
i am a you know robotic version
of who i used to be and it was like yeah
that was like the communists taking over
like people's mentalities where she's
like i will work for
the group i am not an individual this
is a communist propaganda well it was
like it was
it was like it was called pop popular
culture in america through the 1950s
no i mean yeah as america it was like we
watched all american
uh and like read books like american
books and tv shows and [ __ ] and it was
just like
all like it was like so like all of it
was just like
communist propaganda like it was just
like you couldn't find another theme
like at that time in uh america or
yeah in russia
no in america we we didn't watch any
russian [ __ ]
so we didn't see like anti-communism
in the 50s yeah because that was when
america was like oh we're the superpower
what we're going to be about is against
russia that's our whole thing now
what do you mean it's like that was our
cultural drive
it's like the 1950s like we were the
new superpower so we were like let's
[ __ ]
let's [ __ ] with russia that's our duty
as the new super
like when the nerdy kid becomes cool
yeah
because russia was the next step
in human civilization yeah
and they were like we can't have that we
have a good thing going here
jesus well i mean i don't know who knows
what it would be like if russia
got the [ __ ] number one spot yeah
i mean definitely not the best country
to model yourself after with the
i don't know seems a little cold so are
you saying like
our style is just modeled after whatever
russia
is not we're just going to be like i'm
going to be like that i'm going to be
i think we're just feudalism we're just
like a
more slightly more advanced version of
feudalism and then they advance
past what we got past
and they were like let's give the people
a lot of more power and not have any
kings
but then they became kings who stalin
and then they were like we they got rid
of kings and then they became
kings so it's like
why is it always like like communist is
always saying we have the the power the
people have the power but then it's just
always some guy with all the power
um it's too allering
and maybe because they have to fight off
the
rest of the industrialized world so you
need
a leader to fight off an existential
physical violent threat so you're like
well
we believe that uh we should all have
the people have the power
but for right now let's just hire
someone to do
that just get rid of america because it
doesn't work though you're saying like
we always need a leader
we need a leader when someone's trying
to kill us but we need a leader always
we can't make dude imagine do you need a
leader always
uh i always need a boss well a group
needs a leader i mean we can
govern ourselves like hunter-gatherers
don't have leaders dude but there's just
two it's just too many people like
there's too many different opinions and
too many like
which is why we shouldn't have leaders
because there's too many different
opinions and a leader only has one
opinion
yeah but a leader kind of i mean a
leader
you know decides just like that's just
how it's going to be like it like if if
we
as the people tried to to come to a
conclusion we would never
work it out and we need to get a parent
why not why don't we just have a vote
oh and then be like oh that's the vote
and not yet people would be like
no [ __ ] you and like we need a leader to
be like yeah that's it
why why can't we do it ourselves why do
we need a leader people are [ __ ]
stupid and angry then why do
we listen to a leader like what does the
leader solve it's like at the end of the
day
has trust of the people well why don't
we trust each other
because we're [ __ ] insane
that's a illogical story
uh there's like i mean dude there's
so many people in this world who you
wouldn't trust with a decision
yeah that's why we need to uh dilute
that by having everyone
have a little bit of power
uh she'll be like hey you're in charge
of the dogs i'll be in charge of
the cats the cats they're the lizard
shirt
komodo dragons um yeah i mean i guess
some sort of leadership is fine it's
just like
i don't know if they should have a lot
of power i think
people don't like that i think it's only
recently where we're like yeah we need a
king over
us i think i have more faith in humanity
to guide ourselves rather than have some
dude do it
who's apparently speaking for everyone
but i don't know
why don't you just have people everyone
speak for everyone all right so
let's have this as a plan everybody get
all their money
put into a pile like everybody in all
the world puts their money in a pile
yeah and then
we race we raise to it and whoever gets
the most wins
you say bolt he just gets
all the little ron james like just the
biggest humans
and then the same balls like you can't
attack me i got here first and then
[ __ ] the rock is like [ __ ] you
and then the big guys fight and then the
little guys like get the ones that they
they drop like they get the scraps you
know
they weasel their way in there so you
think that winner take all
we have to compete with each other to
see who gets it and
we need to have a cutthroat mentality
no no i actually i don't think that
actually i think
dude i put like so say we put all the
money in a pile and we're like we give
everybody
the equal amount yeah um
there's always going to be guys who
would just like be like hey
can i see yours for a second and then
runs away
but that's why the group is like hey
that one guy stole from us
we are 10 million of us let's go [ __ ]
with that one guy
or the group is like hey wait we can do
that you give me your money and then
everyone starts fighting
and then we're like wait a minute we're
humans we don't have to do this anymore
we can actually evolve and actually like
organize
smart like you but it's not about
intelligence it's about fairness
it's not we're not like this because of
evolution we're like this because one
person gained power and then kept us
like this
who the aristocrats the feudal lords
the corporate overlords
yeah so like yeah so like
hunter-gatherers today of leader
not according to christopher ryan they
were egalitarian fiercely egalitarian if
one person got cocky they murdered him
because there was 20 other people
yeah so there's just too many people i
think
which means we have even more power to
kill individuals
we're like cops
we're like cops we're just all a
population of
cops yeah everyone's a snitch
which i mean what about individual
liberty you know like if
everyone is always afraid of the group
then do individuals ever get to really
be themselves that's the proper critique
of communism
not we need a leader like you're
supposed to be arguing for capitalism
and capitalism loves freedom not leaders
i mean i'm saying i i don't want there
to be a leader but i'm saying like i
i think there usually has to be because
people
don't work well together
what about china i guess china has a
leader
um i mean we don't work well together
so the solution is to constantly not
work well together and have someone tell
us what to do or is it to work well
together maybe we could figure out how
to work well together
um yeah maybe
how do you suggest doing that um have
give everyone food and shelter
and then have a project that we work
towards that way no one's
dying so they don't aren't forced to
steal
or not work well with each other
everyone's like
you know hello we need leaders to say
all right you guys do this
you guys we need leaders to delegate
because people together are not gonna
figure that out i think that people can
be like
this is the project we're working
towards we have 20 people working on the
exhaust we can't have 100 people working
on
the screws that's a bad
look so i think if everyone looks at the
chart of where everyone is they're like
oh let me go here where there's less
people i think people
would be able to decide themselves where
they are most useful and we don't need a
leader to be like oh you need to
work on this yeah
i guess i mean in an ideal world yeah
that makes sense
um i wish i hope that happens
you don't think it can because we're
[Music]
too fighty we're fighting each other and
we can't just stop
or else someone will take everything
yeah
um yeah it's just like i can't like
like it's like i want i was talking
to kid pedro pedro
and he was saying like how we should
just like
i don't know he's talking about like
different policies we should work
together
on like however way like
just change the system and like i was
just like yeah like i don't
i don't have time for that like i need
to
establish myself before i can help
people
but what would you establish yourself
for
if not for the good of the group myself
and then once you're established what
would you do
i guess i just don't want to help but
like
i uh okay at least you're honest no i
mean i do
like i think that would be a better
focus
i can't stop thinking about myself
though
i mean you don't want to be too asian
and just be like
a cog and just like un faceless
human with no personality yeah and i'm
just like working to help other people
and i never get help for myself because
i'm just trying to feed the group
it's like i want to kind of be my own
organism
you are no matter what happens like your
individuality can't be just extinguished
by but it can be tamed
and don't we have a system that does
tame individuality and makes you a
like a dog walker or like a delivery boy
or like a cubicle employee
like that is very defeating to the
individual self where you're just
moving excellent always have to do work
like you can't get out of doing work
but the work we have now isn't helpful
to individuality
like i mean therapist
yeah i just i don't know we could
we could emphasize the individual like
but i don't think we
are it's not like we're helping
individuals
right now we're not like oh you're you
have a unique talent we want to reward
that
no we're just like work at post mates
like we have a culture that does that
where we're like oh stand up comedy or
like
a director but then our economic system
doesn't help individuals
prosper yeah because they don't really
care about stand-up comedy
yeah there's no money in it for open
micro so you just have to like suddenly
be funny all
out of nowhere and then we'll reward you
then we'll
give you what individuals deserve
but um i feel like we could be an
individual
and also you could be a better
individual helping people
finding ways to help in a group because
we are a hive organism
why who said that where did you get that
everything around us
is built by other people like and our
cities
that we live in yeah that's true
it's like there is no self but it's also
but i didn't ask them to do that i mean
the only reason they did that is
so they could get money yeah like they
didn't do that
they did that mainly for themselves
they're like i need a place to live
might as well just build other other
people's places and
they could just pay me for the work like
they didn't i don't think they were just
like
so you think humans are just like
cockroaches they're like
just me me me yeah yeah
but why do they do all that work like
isn't it for the betterment of their
children which is just a
just like a metaphor for the society and
the humanity and like
everyone else that we love so much
our children yeah i don't know
i mean i like there's something in us
where we're just like oh we need to
protect our what that thing that we
created
that's like a rat like your view of
humanity is like
so sad like we're just in it for
ourselves and our children
i mean i don't think there's much else
like i don't like
i don't know like why do you go to 6th
street like
because i don't know what else to do i
don't know i don't know i would just
like
just stimulate it by seeing all those
people
no i'm not like a great simulation but i
love going there to feel the energy of
all the people like
people the group like we're part of this
huge
beast and it's cool like we're a voltron
and we're like the little toenails on
the voltron
and it's cool to be part of this great
organism that
destroyed the world
yeah i don't really think about it like
that i'm just like i like
well i know you're talking about where i
can feel the energy like if you're in
like a theater
like and it's you ever been in the
theater and it's dark and you can just
feel everyone around you yeah uh i think
that's cool but like
i don't really like um
it doesn't really like give me a sense
of purpose like i'm just like oh that's
a cool thing
but like i said genzi dude like i don't
know like i just [ __ ]
yeah i'm just not stimulated i'm just
like here like doing [ __ ]
i don't know what to do
yeah i mean there's i'm stimulated by
comedy but like
honestly like minimally like i like it
could be like a lot more like i
felt a lot more stimulation from like
like a girl that i liked
or yeah like
i don't know if but i feel like girls
are
like you get to interact with the part
of humanity
like you're tapping into other people
it's just one-on-one though i know it's
but it's intense
it's like instead of getting to know 100
people
their names you're getting to know the
vagina of another person
like you know like so you're getting a
lot of stimulation
from one person getting to know another
person so you're still
i don't know it's it's still like the
same thing i guess but
i i guess it is like with other people i
i think differently
i learn different things different ways
to feel different ways to think and it's
uh yeah it's cool like seeing people's
perspective on things
but a lot of time like a lot of the
people i meet are just like
i've i put them in like an archetype
like oh i've met that type of person
before
i've been around these type of people i
know who they are yeah
like i like it's just like you can have
different experiences you can grow up
somewhere else
but like it's just like you are similar
to the person i've
i've seen before it's just like i don't
notice like
yeah i don't know notice the differences
i don't notice a lot of differences and
i'm just like oh you're just a guy like
you're just a girl you're
you're your experiences are boring to me
but you love talking to people not
really you're always talking to somebody
i talk to people
because there's nothing else to do and i
don't want to like stand there by myself
i talk to people because like people
talk to me and i just like [ __ ]
or i have something i want to say or
but a lot of time when i'm having a
conversation with someone i'm just like
i don't know it's just like go through
the motions of conversation i have a lot
of the same conversations over and over
again
but i i think that's your super computer
just finding patterns and
learning how to spend the least amount
of energy possible
but if you wanted to be fascinated by
people
i mean i think you are i think you do
like people
yeah i mean i'm i don't yeah i don't
hate them
like if they were all gone i'd be really
sad and kill myself
yeah i got maybe i just need a break
dude i think i just need to like step
like i think i am
like a true introvert like sometimes i
am extroverted but like
i need to recharge like away from people
like i need like i'm [ __ ] burnt out
like
a little bit maybe it's the type of
interactions
like of like the open micro or like
strangers where are you from
how you been how tall is your tree i
don't know
what that was but if you're like
having a conversation with like a friend
of yours that was a helicopter pilot
and you had known each other for seven
years maybe that would be more
stimulating but we are we're like
constantly surrounded by strangers so
we're having the same
type of conversations even like my my
longtime friends i call
and i'm like uh
like like i yeah
i don't know i
yeah i'd rather just someone be around
me and not really say much
but just like they're emotional just so
you know energy is around me
yeah like i'd rather yeah i just i'd
rather just
like sit next to someone and not talk
because you get the best of both worlds
i just don't talk
can you imagine if i was on a date it
just
did not say anything
hey what's up thanks so um
so yeah it's great to be here yeah like
how are you
uh yeah no i'm not even saying it's good
energy
just
just like flat face uh
yeah so what what did you do what do you
want to eat
did you see anything you liked
wow i think the uh this place is nice
man thanks uh yeah so what
um yeah how'd you meet uh vanessa how do
you
because i know you we met through
vanessa
wow it was a very realistic day
i don't know that so you would just like
soak in
soak in her energy
yeah i'm just yeah
so he's just like an old married couple
you want to get to that place
instantly i mean dude like that
is like dude i mean a lot of the things
we say are just words
like it's just like we're just talking
because we can
yeah i know it's just like we don't need
to talk we could just [ __ ]
but it's just like it's not it's it's so
awkward when you don't talk
i mean but i don't know why that is like
because we're intellectual beings we're
so used to hearing sexual
doesn't matter what the noise is if
you're talking you're saying
[Music]
like it's just like it would be better
like people are more comfortable with
that just hearing [ __ ]
[ __ ] no [ __ ] yeah so i'm from arkansas
my family you're not saying anything
yeah it's just like stupid
[ __ ] thinking of bad [ __ ] about me so i
need to constantly poke you and be like
you're not gonna rape me right you're
not gonna murder me okay good what about
now what about now
yeah yeah it's just like what's going on
inside your head i'm
trying to understand what you're
thinking but like when i'm
but but then when you talk it's just
like oh thank god he's saying [ __ ]
thank god i just need them to talk but
when they talk you don't actually care
yeah it's just like yeah oh my god i
don't know why we do that because it's
the stupidest [ __ ] thing
but like it is creepy like yeah if we
just stared at each other
it would be creepy but like why it like
because is that just because you we have
computers in our brain that need to be
engaged
otherwise it's just like staring at a
rock
or an object so words conversation or
just like
cables we're plugging in yeah it's like
so
dumb dude oh hell we should be on
bluetooth
i mean right now that's even more dumb
no because then we don't have to like
plug anything right and we can just
oop show up we're automatically
connected
yeah true i mean just because you
have great conversations or like you can
fill in the gaps in the silence doesn't
mean you're gonna be compatible
sexually yeah i know it and honestly
conversations like
like don't even provide that much
emotion it's just like
words yeah it's just it's just filler
words
it's just like [ __ ] you have to get
through to get to the actual good stuff
yeah and it's like i don't know why we
do that we're like i gotta dress up i
gotta put on makeup i gotta
i gotta make it should be i'm gonna make
all this [ __ ] and then eventually i can
be comfortable around a person
we it's basically like playing chess to
figure out if you
are compatible as a couple it's like an
intellectual game
that is it that we just have to do it
because it's the
we have a chess board we have a chess
set all the time
you know like we're we have a like
playing fortnite
you gotta collect the [ __ ] even though
it's boring you ever play fortnite
no well you know how like you you land
on a place on a map and you
you collect all sorts of resources so
you can go into battle
because like you start with nothing yeah
but you have to like find chess
and objects and get guns and stuff and
it's just like it's the same boring [ __ ]
every time you have to like
harvest material and it's so mundane but
you have to have it
to get haven't had a conversation with a
girl that was really good that made you
actually more interested
and like when it's right when it's good
it's great
like yeah that's true yeah if you have a
great conversation on a date
but like when when it's great though
it's not about the conversation
it's about like the emotional connection
it's just like
it's just like yeah like you you could
be joking around about anything you
could be talking about anything but
you're having a good time because you're
emotionally connected
and it's just like the words don't
matter but the words are what get you
there
so it's like you gotta get good at that
game to tap into the emotions
the words are not that important i feel
like because you
you pretty much already have an idea in
your mind if you like someone or not
like yeah no matter what they say i mean
if they say you can use those words
to get those emotions so if you can't i
mean it's hard
but that doesn't mean it's yeah yeah i
mean
it is very hard definitely no i mean i
guess like that's why
that's why conversation is so mundane a
lot is because
words can either get the person to
really like you
or hate you you know it's just like if i
said if i said something really
vulgar and gross you'd be like i don't
wanna this person has this disgusting
mind
yeah if i'd say something like really
loving be like oh like i'm attracted to
this person
but like we try to keep it most in the
middle a lot of the time or it's just
like stupid [ __ ]
because we don't want to because
we're supposed to act professional or
some [ __ ] it's just like
you know you know like you're talking to
someone in a professional way
yeah it's just like
yeah it's just the safe it's yeah it's
just like i don't know getting to the
next
point without rocking the boat yeah yeah
you're just making noise trying not to
it's neutral
[ __ ] anything up here's everyone
switzerland
[Laughter]
yeah everyone's trying not to engage and
not trying to make an impact
yeah it's [ __ ] stupid but like i dude
this game
sucks this game sucks it does suck
dating like talking no no no
not dating life like being human
dude this game is not that fun dude
because of capitalism
it's not but uh i okay i don't get why
people like it so much it's so boring
we're on this planet and we have an
ability to impact the society it's crazy
that we're alive right now
we get to go out there and burn a
building if we want to
we can do things consequently like
yeah i mean okay so sorry um i heard i
saw this documentary about this dude
that [ __ ] donkeys
in like venezuela or somewhere it's like
a tradition they [ __ ] donkeys
and then they [ __ ] women and they like
practice compare donkeys
yeah they compare donkeys to women and
this guy who started out as a kid
[ __ ] donkeys and usually grow out of
it but he'd never grow out of it
[ __ ] up he as a kid yeah he would [ __ ]
donkeys like 12 like adolescents
and they're just getting boners yeah
it was like when i was first jerking off
that's like going straight
it's like jerking off with a donkey and
it's a culture of it
so it's not looked down as weird as we'd
look at it but
this guy never grew out of it and he's
and they asked him why and he's like
with women there's too much
talking like you have to guess what
they're thinking and i what i think they
used
the phrase like there's too many mind
games
and with a donkey it's just like oh i
have a [ __ ] come [ __ ] me
it's like it's just right there the
donkey said that with their eyes all
right so it is
jesus christ so um you can go [ __ ] a
donkey if you're tired of talking to
women
dude uh so everyone is way more
complicated
what's like a large portion of the
population
oh yeah i mean i think that's why porn
is so popular
you don't have to try to excrete
your dna
yeah but i mean like [ __ ] women is a
very specific skill but it's
uh the one that we have
and it is like sort of weird and dumb
[ __ ] a donkey though
i bet but that's not the game that we
have
you know like this is the game that yeah
that's like a
viewer like we're like all right we're
playing monopoly wait why are you
playing charlotte why are you [ __ ] a
donkey yeah
do you wait what do you i thought this
was that we were going to play this
yeah they're [ __ ] a donkey and he's
like dude
this game is just a lot more simple like
i want to play monopoly dude yeah
there's too many pieces yeah
you gotta get exactly right but
the tail pin i mean penis on the
case vagina wait so what is this culture
of [ __ ] it's on
vice it's like did the camera go out
no is that did it it just clicked oh
yeah i thought it was the door
i guess it went out we did an hour
do we do an hour
yeah within an hour oh do you want to
just finish this donkey
thing yeah let's come in the donkey and
call it a day all right so uh yeah so
what is this culture of donkey
[ __ ] it's in latin america somewhere
and every so like they they every kid
[ __ ] a donkey um
some most like a majority of them
just to learn how to have sex
i mean i feel like it's hard it'd
probably be harder to [ __ ] a donkey than
a woman
they probably have bigger to get a step
stool like yeah
um yeah and
geez and when you're 12 you're not even
that big anyway like
so the donkey's like oh it's that little
dick [ __ ] they don't respect you
well the donkeys and that's just
the donkeys in that specific reason are
like they they travel to other donkeys
they're like wait you
wait kids don't [ __ ] you guys we have to
do that all the time that's like part of
our culture
the donkeys are like horny for little
kids yeah all right yeah so do you guys
want to like go find some uh
young men or the age of 12 and she's
like whoa whoa
the only [ __ ] donkey is here what are
you doing i thought we
i thought that's what we were uh but
like they're like
doing their makeup doing their doing
their maine
to go out to the city to try to pick up
some young boys
go out to the chuck e cheese uh
so and then and then when do they start
[ __ ] women when they
when they whenever they can so that's
just like a training bra
yeah that must be such a relief
to be like finally [ __ ] up oh thank god
i don't have a [ __ ] donkey anymore
that's like an extra motivator to lose
your virginity yeah dude
oh my god
like lucky you have a girlfriend at the
[ __ ] donkey every night
dude i would like why would you want to
do that in the first place like because
it's
like you were talking because like you
were being an incel just 10 minutes ago
what what did i say you're like i have
to talk to women
i have to actually ask for consent i
never said that
don't make me say that dude i'm just
saying like i'm just more bored with
people in general mind games
like you have to guess what they're
feeling and like oh you didn't know that
i was cold
i'm not gonna have sex with you now no
it's like a bunch of [ __ ] with a
donkey it's just like yeah i'm horny
let's
i have a vagina put it in let's go uh
put it on let's go and then get on my
back and i'll drive you home
i'm like why don't you [ __ ] me while i'm
taking you home um
so uh yeah no i'm not saying that i like
am bored with women specifically i'm
just bored with people in general like i
don't like
i'm like like having a relationship with
someone is so much work
like even just a friend or you know it's
just like
it's like a team effort i'm like i don't
like
feel like doing it like i don't want
like it's so
boring like i don't i don't want to put
in the effort basically it's just but
everything can be
interesting or boring like every
activity is
uh you could be obsessed with or not and
it's like a skill to be obsessed with
things so it's like a skill to be
interested
so like yeah i don't know i used to be
interested in things but now i'm just
like
so bored like it's like like i
felt like yeah i think it's because of
capitalism
i don't know maybe i'm depressed but
like i just like capitalism
i don't know maybe i don't know
but i just like yeah it's just like
i mean hopefully you feel like what you
your life matters and
the things that you pursue matter and if
it doesn't feel like it
it is because you get to impact other
people who can impact
the society we live in which will impact
the planet which will impact the
universe
yeah but why does that matter this is
just like uh
because we are the only sentient beings
in the known universe and we can do
anything we want to but that doesn't
mean we have to do it
no we could do nothing if we want but
the fact that we have the choice
and that we got to make a decision we
have we got to take a part in that
decision is
kind of cool yeah
it's cool i guess it's like definitely
i guess yeah it's like the elbow thing
is so build a tv
build a iphone do it
podcast yeah who cares
start in only men's club
men's men's okay so
um is there
do you know if there's a donkey shelter
near here or
i mean we could get a flashlight
it's like a mobile donkey in the shape
of a donkey
it smells like donkey uh um
yeah norm has this great bit about uh
like people who [ __ ] animals and um
um like the animals probably like
or like like he saw i don't know like he
saw like this woman who's like being
[ __ ] by like a
whatever kind of animal like a horse you
know
and it's just like like the horse is
probably
like the horse like having to go back to
horse [ __ ] it's just like ugh
like you can't like it's just like oh i
gotta like [ __ ] a horse now i
got to [ __ ] this beautiful woman and now
i gotta [ __ ] a horse again
oh they're loose ass horse [ __ ] yeah
giant
gigantic horse [ __ ] um dude animals
like treat sex in like
like how do you think they think about
sex like
animals have sex to create children
that's pretty much it
i think they do it because they have
this uncontrollable urge
to mount another animal i don't think
they're like i must
procreate let me go over to this female
i think it's just like
oh my god what was that noise that noise
is triggering
[ __ ] in my brain but the the the female
species have like
they usually are like decide if he's
like
a good mate you know yeah
um but like i mean do you think they
think about sex like
like we do or do you think they crave
sex
yeah but not for the same reasons we do
or
for the same reasons um i think
more monkeys yeah
definitely i would love to see a monkey
jerk off
that'd be hilarious you could do it
right now on youtube or
x videos so funny
um monkeys are crazy because like they
um they can't really talk or like they
have like the same facial expression and
they just like do random [ __ ] like
they'll just like i saw
a monkey just grab a guy's balls and
just like
like with like so casually you know like
a human couldn't do that a human
borat does it right yeah but he says
things
monkeys are communicating with body
language and
energy all right well do you want to
wrap this up like a
chipotle burrito which by the way they
don't rap
at all they they don't even [ __ ] try
i'm like like don't tell me yeah like
that [ __ ] bo burnham like song where
it's just like i wouldn't have got
this stuff if i knew it wouldn't fit
tell me it's not gonna fit
don't be like okay do you want what else
do you want
you know better than i do what's gonna
fit in there or not yeah
i was working at a subway and i someone
ordered a meatball sandwich which is
already pretty big
and they put like lettuce and tomato and
[ __ ] on it and i was like okay i guess
i'm making this and then i like try to
close
it and it was like that big and yeah
what an [ __ ] dude
an [ __ ] me no the guy yeah it's like
why are you putting all this [ __ ] in
here and then expecting it to close
yeah it's like look at it like
physically judge it don't just be like
oh i'm just
a build-a-bear i want this build-a-bear
to have a hat and a sunglasses
whatever but yeah let's wrap it up like
a burrito
okay yeah this was a better one this is
probably our best one
we're getting looser i'm loose like a
donkey vagina
they probably don't even feel it like
dude but like imagine your
your parents are like all right happy
12th birthday
you're gonna go [ __ ] a donkey just like
i don't really
it's like yup put your penis in there
you're looking at
donkey playboy
yeah they get you like donkey sensitive
condoms
ribbed ribs for the junkies
pleasure it's got like giant ribs on it
to make your [ __ ] horse-sized anyways i
gotta go i guess
your friends uh yeah you should have
seen the donkey i [ __ ] this weekend
dude that's insane man
you should watch it it's a pretty crazy
vice video yeah
um okay well um you know
have uh have a good day everyone and um
do you have anything you want to say
yeah um
let's uh power to the people
power to the grid
the user all right well
uh see ya bye